our nation is facing a challenge unlike
its faced in decades there is anger
there's frustration there's fear there's
exhaustion and the question is is how do
we get through this most people want to
talk to Curtis Martin because of his
football career but I wanted to talk to
Curtis because of the way he sees the
world the way he understands people the
way he goes through life the insights he
has the lessons he's learned I think
will help us navigate as we go through
this together because we have to get
through this together this is a bit of
optimism Curtis I have so much respect
for the way you see the world and your
to me you're like a you're like a monk
you have such a such a calmness but also
such insight into how people work and
how the world works and given everything
that our nation is going through right
now you're one of the first people I
wanted to talk to to find out how you
feel about everything what you're
thinking about yeah well you know Simon
the one thing that I think I feel is
something different right there's been
other situations like Trayvon Martin or
Fionna Taylor Eric garner and those are
something that if you're in a black
community they resonate with you but I
don't know what it is and I'm not saying
that their deaths was any different than
George Floyd's but I do think that
there's just something a little
different I think there's a different
fire I think that black people in black
communities when you see a cop kneeling
on another black man's neck like that
it does something to you because most of
us especially the males in the black
community we've had some type of
experience where we know that that could
have very easily been us and so I think
this was somewhat the tipping point and
I think that's what we're seeing play
out in society I think what's so
different about this one versus the
tragic long list of others is is that
this is the first time that the entire
scene was captured on film you know the
other ones we we heard the story or we
saw a photograph of what happened
afterwards and there was always there
was always the the quote-unquote police
report of they were violent or they were
armed or they reached for something and
and the reality is the black community
didn't believe that and the rest of us
didn't know and for the first time we
saw but the black community have already
known for ages yeah that the police
report that they filed was was fake to
cover up what they Eve even even with
the footage they still there's still a
fake police report for the first time we
saw the whole thing
beginning to end and it struck us it
struck the rest of America as hard as it
always strikes the black community and
you know something Simon when I think
back to it the first time I I saw that
video what really touched me was when I
saw this strong grown black man on the
ground with a white guy with his knee on
his neck in this strong black man starts
crying out for his mother and he saying
mama you know but there's something
about that that resonates with all of us
black and white and then what really I
think made it sink into I know for me
and I can't speak for everyone else was
when I saw the guy you know I believe he
urinated and it's fight you just saw the
life go out of here
and so you literally got to sit and
watch someone murder someone like
blow-by-blow on tape upon video and you
have to think a lot of work
kids are exposed to this type of thing
and it was just something that was in my
mind so cruel it's one of the cruelest
things I've seen I'm not a cruel things
in my life Simon but that was just an
extremely cruel thing to me and I think
to all of us
I've had some difficult conversations
with black friends with white friends
and one of the things that I've I've
come to realize is I have anger you have
anger but the difference is is my anger
is not laced with fear right and as a
black friend of mine shared with me is
not only is my anger not laced with fear
my anger is also not laced with
exhaustion and we're where I have found
myself weeping in some of these
conversations it's choking me up now as
I find myself we peek at some of these
conversations my black friends aren't we
pink and I asked them how come I'm cut
up and you're not and they said because
this has affected me everything I've
seen this over and over and over again
I'm exhausted my friends tell me where
for us because for white America goes
it's the first time we've seen the whole
the whole scene at play out and we
haven't had the same experiences I I
haven't had an experience with a with a
police officer like you have that for
the first time it was deeply deeply
personal you know I think that white
America got a glimpse of what black
America literally lives with all of our
lives yeah it's been like that since as
long as I can remember I grew up in an
extremely abusive household where my
father was strung out on drugs and
extremely abusive to my mother but you
know what in that community and even all
the neighbors because we lived in a
project type of environment but you know
what Simon nobody wanted to call the
cops in the black community calling the
cops is like your master resort that's
just like you're at the end of your rope
you would rather suffer many times with
what you're dealing with in your
community your household or whatever it
may be before you call the cops because
even back then I knew it
years oh four years old right you don't
pick up the phone there was many times
with I wanted to call the cops on my
father but that's just something that
you know you do not do in the black
community and mainly because we know
that we may call the cops because of
this bad situation that's going on in
our household but when the cops get
there more than likely and that's just
the mindset that bad situation is going
to turn into a worse situation yeah the
escalation and so imagine you know most
of us live with that type of you know
you talk about the fear but we live with
that fear on top of the distrust on top
of the you know
of injustice that we've witnessed in our
own communities all the time and so
there's this distrust you know a lot of
times for the police and it's not to say
that all police are bad or anything you
know because there's a lot of us who
have been through a whole lot of
adversity in some horrible situations
and the police were were there for us
but then you see something like what
happened to George Floyd and it almost
throws you back into this distrustful
state the thing that I've come to love
and admire about you is you have this
intense optimism that you know you grew
up in them the most horrendous of
conditions you know as you said abusive
father you watched your mother getting
tortured you've witnessed your friends
being killed
you've had your life threatened and yet
still you you still remain positive and
forward-thinking and in the face of
extreme pain you know how to move
forwards and I think in this time of
pain and fear I you know how what can we
learn how do we move through pain where
where does this go well you know some
sign I think what would help so many
people I think what would help America
with the pain is if these cops are if
justice is served because I think that
it would be a huge hole in the heart of
America if these guys got off like so
many other people have gotten off in
situations like this yeah if that
happens this time you know I don't know
what will happen I'm afraid of what will
happen if that happens this time
the thing that I'm also starting to
understand is you know it's it's not
enough to put band-aids on these
situations anymore which is there has to
be systemic change so that we prevent
this from happening exactly and again I
think that is difficult for a specific
group of people to continually feel like
they're being treated unfairly you know
just for instance if I'm a white person
and I'm in a community calling the cops
is the first thing I do if something's
really wrong because I'm not worried
about how things might be
interpret it if I might get blamed for
something you know it you don't think
that way or most people don't think that
way when you're a white person but when
you're a black person you always have to
think twice and I think what we're
seeing in our society Simon there's a
group of people who are losing hope and
I think the fighting in the in the
protesting and everything I think that
it's a cry out for you know give us
something to hope for
yeah you know so so I think the
injustice part of it is causing people
to lose hope of just basic fairness and
so I that's best the level of intensity
and anger and aggression you know that
we're seeing throughout the streets of
America I think it's a result of that
you've been able to move through pain in
your life there have to be some
transferable lessons yes what what can
like what can we learn you've done it
you've done it in your life does it work
at a societal level does it work for a
community I think that it works for
community I think it works in a society
because I think that you know it's the
individuals that make up the community
in the society so I think that if we
could learn how to use this pain and
frustration or whatever it may be
and pull something positive out of it on
an individual level I think it
translates into a community level
eventually if enough of us can do that
but that's very difficult and remember
Simon just take my life for instance you
know this kid who grows up in this
abusive household and you know 30 40 and
my friends were murdered you know we
found my grandmother murdered with a
knife in her chest but everywhere my on
is burned to death and I have a friend
who's wrapped up in the carpet and the
carpet is beat with bats until you know
they die they and you see all of this
type of stuff growing up and then you
know you get in a situation and this
happened to me personally where I'm
racially profiled now most of us who
grow up under those circumstances you
know sometimes we may not have the
composure are the peaceful words are the
compliance that that's being demanded of
us in that moment and you know I saw
this thing on Instagram where a young
man was pulled over the young guy gets
out of his car the cop tells him to get
out of his car and he's saying officer
you know what did I do wrong and officer
who says just put your hands up and get
on the ground and the guys like just
tell me what I did wrong officer and the
guy literally has his hands all the way
up and the officer says get on the
ground
in the guy's fight and the guy's
girlfriend is recording all this going
on in the guys just officer I just want
to know why I am being pulled over like
why are you telling me to get on the
ground I didn't do anything
I'm keeping my hands up isn't that
enough and officer keeps demanding for
him to get on the ground and the guy
just said no I'm not getting on the
ground but my hands are up I don't have
anything on me or anything and the
officer tries to come over there and
like notch him up and and you know in
that moment when you have a guy who may
have grown up the way I grew up again in
that moment when it's such an unjust
situation
it's hard to keep your composure when
you feel like you're being cheated on
stare so what that guy did when the cop
tried to grab him he just like he didn't
touch the copper or anything he just
like shrugged the cup off of him with
his shoulders and stuff and then the cup
you know pulls back from and pulls out
his I'm not sure if it was his taste or
his gun
we cut can't really tell from the video
and the guy asked could you just please
call your senior you know officer or
whatever to come to the scene and the
guy and his girlfriend are demanding
that this guy's senior senior officer
comes to the scene the senior officer
comes to the same Simon and you know the
guy feels a little relieved so he turns
around with his hands up to go and talk
to the senior police officer this guy
doesn't ask any questions or anything
swatch straight towards the guy grabs
him by the neck and rams him into the
car and then the guys caught off guard
and he's just trying to Mike you know he
doesn't know what's going on in that
situation you don't know if someone's
trying to kill you or what because he
didn't even ask the question and and so
they grab him they both get on top of
him they may start pummeling this guy
and take him to the ground and they're
punching on him and everything and again
Simon the frustration you know how it is
when you know you haven't done anything
wrong and someone's treating you unfair
and then you're expected to comply with
every little thing that someone who's
treating you unfair to do I think what
the way that guy reacted is the
pervasive mentality in the black
community right now people are just
tired and like you said when we start
this conversation exhausted mmm my
question is so where's the leadership
you know I'm tired of press conferences
where a police chief stands up and says
it's a it's just a few bad apples
you know the whole saying which is never
said the whole saying is a few bad
apples spoils the whole barrel and we
now have a pervasive problem in the in
the profession of policing that goes way
deeper than a few bad apples and so my
question is is where's the leadership
there needs to be massive
have reformed in the police departments
and leadership needs to recognize that
the manner in which they recruit has to
change they could no longer recruit to a
paramilitary ideal they have to recruit
to a service ideal because you'll you
don't want to attract people who want a
paramilitary drop job you want to
attract people who want to serve their
community there needs to be leadership
training promoting people who are good
leaders not just promoting people who
are high performers are writing enough
tickets or making enough arrests there
needs to be new metrics on what it means
to be a good police officer we need
systemic change inside these
organizations otherwise this is gonna
continue I agree with that I agree for
the calls to ban a particular move you
know a chokehold or something but that
that won't solve a problem why is it you
know I am originally from England
a long time ago and and the cops for the
most part don't carry guns in the UK and
I've talked to cops in the UK and they
find it astonishing that police here you
know draw their guns as often as they do
and I asked a cop in England I said what
do you do if a guy attacks you with a
knife he goes we know how to disarm them
like they're trained with their hands
and their batons to disarm an attack and
I asked I've asked cops in the United
States I said what do you do if a guy
lunges at you say oh you shoot him you
know where's the in-between I understand
the the choice to use mortal force in
the face of a mortal threat but with
that there's there needs to be dramatic
and significant and substantial change
inside the organisation's
not just the moves that they're banning
or not banning and and the manner in
which these organizations are led
otherwise this will never change I agree
this opportunity where for the first
time we have all seen the full video
this opportunity will be squandered
there's amazing rise of understanding of
the desire to listen that people
understand the difference between being
non racist and being anti-racist that
one requires action the other one is
passive the
the this mirror that's been held up that
there is accountability as a nation as a
policing profession as a white race we
have to take advantage of this
astonishing opportunity of all of these
things coming together well Simon you
know and you and I have spoken before
about my perspective on problems right
mm-hmm I believe it on the other side
that every problem is an opportunity I
actually believe that we have to be very
careful about the way we view our
problems because hidden behind our
problems and some of our biggest
problems are usually some of our biggest
opportunities and some of our greatest
blessings and I this is a huge problem
in our society today I think there's a
tremendous opportunity for change I
think there's a tremendous opportunity
for leadership and the reason why I
think that this is different Simon is
because I think not only black people
but white people and all people are
demanding change and I don't think that
things will return to normal it may take
a while for that change to be realized
over a period of time but I do believe
it there will be policies and different
things that are done from a legal level
that will hopefully prevent some of
these things from happening in the
future and the black community is
definitely going to demand it and we've
demanded it before but like I said I
think the world is different I believe
hitting behind some of our biggest
problems are some of our biggest
blessings and some of our greatest
opportunities a lot of times we fear the
pain that that problem was going to
bring into our lives so we may sweep a
problem under the rug or try to avoid a
problem but I believe that in avoiding
that problem and avoiding challenging
yourself within that problem you're also
avoiding the blessing or the opportunity
or the reward that was on the other side
of that problem so I believe that
problems happen and not referring to
necessarily you know what the world is
dealing with now just on a individual
level I believe that problems
happened for five reasons in our lives
and those reasons are you know to
correct you inspect you direct you
protect you and perfect you I believe
that every problem that we go through on
an individual basis will fall under one
of those categories that problem will
either direct you inspect you correct
you protect you or protect you and a lot
of times we never really get to see why
these things are happening in our lives
but life doesn't work by just going so
good and being so peaceful all the time
sometimes you meet that challenge in
order to make a change in your life are
to do whatever it is that you could
possibly do in the world one of the
biggest problems for me as a 20 year old
other than overcoming the environment
that I grew up in was when I was leaving
college and trying to decide whether or
not to go into the NFL right now the
coach posed an extreme problem for me he
said he didn't want me to leave college
early so he somewhat threatened me and
told me that it was a bonehead decision
and told me that he was gonna go tell
all the media about the bone decision
that I was about to make and you know
basically just wanted to totally
discourage me and in hindsight I wanted
to try to give you the benefit of the
doubt and say that he just wanted to
keep one of the best players on the team
in college for another year and somewhat
rightfully so because I had been injured
almost every single year during my
college career so the likelihood of me
surviving the NFL just wasn't Michael
but I remember going to my coach and
saying coach listen I've been struggling
with this you know idea of either going
into the pros or coming back to college
for another year and literally I closed
it just like that Simon and the coach
went off on me you know he said why
would you even be thinking about
something like that you can't even play
a full season in college what makes you
think you can survive any NFL that is
one of the dumbest decisions that I've
never even heard if this is what you're
thinking he said listen I'm about to go
over to the press conference and i'ma
tell the entire Kix Berg media about the
Bonilla
that Curtis Martin is about to make you
know some Simon as I left his office I
remember before I walked out the door I
looked at him and I said you know what
coach thank you because the one thing
that I know is that I won't be coming
back here next year I thought I was but
you helped me make my decision and
that's what I came for it didn't come in
the package that I wanted it to coach
but thank you because one thing I know
is that I'm either going into the NFL
I'm going home I am NOT coming back to
college now but at the end of the day
Simon that turned out to be the best
decision for me that first year I wanted
to the NFL I had an incredible year I
went to the Pro Bowl and got Rookie of
the Year and everyone told me I would
you know play in the NFL and thereafter
you know I've had a successful career
and finish to the Hall of Fame but at
the end of the day if I was afraid to
deal with that fear to not step up to
just kind of sweep it under the rug and
and and and accept that I don't even
think we'd be on his phone having a
conversation Simon because when he
presented that problem to me when I said
when I felt the disdain that he had
towards me in that moment you know I
wasn't always kind of refined the way I
am you know I was just young kind of guy
who just came out of the streets of
Pittsburgh and so back then I just said
all right well now it's me against you
and it wasn't about proving him wrong as
as much as it was proving myself right
but that problem directed me because it
definitely changed my direction from
thinking I was going to come back to
college to going into the NFL it
inspected me because it made me really
dig deep and look at who I was and what
I believed in what I wanted to do and
then it corrected me because a lot of
the things that he said about me as a
coach was actually true because I didn't
take football serious I didn't work
really hard so I started working harder
than I've ever worked before in my life
and it protected me because I don't
think that I would be in a situation I
am now had I gone back to college for
another year and ultimately I believe
all those things work together to
perfect us little by little and so
that's my perspective on problems can
you tell me the story of when you got
injured
when you hurt your shoulder in a game oh
yeah so so I think we were playing the
New York Giants and it was probably the
fourth game of the season I get the ball
I have about a 10 12 yard run and I get
hit and my whole shoulder pops out of
socket I'm talking about it's totally I
can't even move my shoulder and they
take me to the sidelines and the doctor
looks at me and you can see my shoulder
kind of the bone sticking up not out of
my skin but you can see that it wasn't
in in place and so the doctor tells the
coach he says he's done and I look at
him I said what do you mean by done said
you're probably gonna have to have to
get this surgically repaired and I said
so this my season's over he said it
looks like it that's they were listening
doc take me back up i I want to get back
in the game and he says you can't take a
shoulder up for you to go back and your
shoulders out of socket and so what I
eventually did had them do was to take
my arm against my sternum so that I
couldn't move that arm I could just move
from my elbow down to my hand to hold a
ball but I couldn't lift my arms up over
my head or anything like that and I
asked him if I can go back in the game I
asked the coach if I could go back in
the game and I asked the doctor said doc
can this get any worse
he said no occurs I mean it is what it
is so I go back in again I get the ball
Simon and when I knew I was about to get
tackled
instead of shriveling up in protecting
that shorter and I rammed that shoulder
into the defenders helmet as hard as I
could
Simon I'm telling you the pain that I
felt shoot through my body was just like
shocking and I remember lying on the
ground and I kept telling myself get up
can I get up and even though it was so
painful I made my way back to the huddle
and in my mind Simon I defeated that
pain because I told myself if I could
just make it back to the huddle I'm okay
and then I took another play and I made
it back to the huddle and so on and so
on
and before long before that game was
over I had already made up in my mind
that I could play the entire season with
that shoulder in that condition and I
ended up him
seasons that year the thing that I loved
about that story is that when we
perceive a problem that it's
overwhelming like you couldn't imagine
finishing the game with that shoulder
but what you could do was you could get
back to the huddle and I just I just
love that that when we're overwhelmed by
a problem that we need two things one to
stay keep our eyes on the prize to
understand the vision of where we're
trying to get to and then take the
smallest smallest step to get there can
I get back to huddle can I get back to
the huddle can I get back to the huddle
and it turns out you can finish a whole
game if you keep betting but getting
back to the huddle and then all of a
sudden finishing game isn't so
overwhelming anymore with a busted
shoulder yeah I just I just love that
yeah people always ask me do I miss the
game and my my first response is always
no but what I do miss are the lessons
that I've learned through football you
know for me that's an invaluable lesson
so that lesson the way it registers in
my mind is just get back to the huddle
no matter what I'm going through if it's
in my marriage and my wife and I you
know have a you know an argument or
something you know get back to the
huddle you know like this is not the end
of the world you can deal with this pain
deal with it don't don't avoid it but
deal with it and so I'd apply principles
like that to my entire life for the best
in business whether that spiritually or
emotionally and usually getting rid of
the pain means exempting ourselves or
removing ourselves from the situation
that's painful but what if we would take
the other approach and dive in even
deeper and go through that pain and come
out on the other side like that's what
I've learned to do in life and it's been
one of the greatest lessons that I've
learned in my life I remember reading
this Bible verse one day and it talked
about Jesus and it said because of the
glory that was set before him Christ
endured the cross and what his saying is
that Jesus had his eyes set on the way
him dying on that cross was going to
help so many people and inspire so many
people and you know and I'm not pushing
beliefs on anyone but just talking about
the Bible
it says you know
because of that vision of what was on
the other side of that cross that's what
helped Jesus and door to cross see I
believe that we all have our own
personal crust in life and a lot of
times instead of enduring that cross we
try to avoid it and in avoiding that
like I say we also avoid that blessing
those people whose lives we could have
touched because I'm out of time so I
mean life isn't just about you out of
the pain that you're gone through isn't
just for you the pain that Martin Luther
King went through just wasn't just for
him it's benefiting us today you know
the pain that I'm going through right
now it's gonna benefit my daughters in
my household in my grandchildren one day
you know so the pain that we go through
isn't just for us and if we can keep our
eyes somewhat focused on the greater
good that will come out of the pain I
think it gives us the motivation to
endure this is a this is an important
point when you talk about the glory you
know you're talking about positive
things and when you invoke Martin Luther
King you know what he what what was such
a turning point in America is when he he
talked about an affirmative vision of
the future a vision that we wanted to
live in and it was not about living
without it was about living with it was
not about ending something but starting
something you know I have a dream that
one day little black children would play
on the playground with little white
children which we could see that and we
wanted that vision we still want that
vision and when we talked about ending
police brutality for example that is one
one of the complicated steps along the
way but it's the glory as affirmative
not-
it's not about ending something or
stopping something it's about getting to
something that's beautiful and that's
what you're talking about right exactly
that's what kept you going in that game
it's what keeps you going in your life
it's what helps you endure pain and
suffering which is you you take these
steps to go toward something glorious
not to end something painful yeah the
one thing I think that we all just have
to accept is that pain is a part of life
and you know I always say that pain is
just a part of the process for you to
get to where you're going
and and what I've often found is that
pain is literally an opportunity to
upgrade and and if we can just deal with
the pain you know in my gym I had this
sign up that says all pain is temporary
you know pain doesn't last forever but a
lot of times when we're in the midst of
pain it can feel like it lasts forever
and that's what discourages us but I
hope that what I'm able to pass down to
my kids into my sphere the people around
me is how to challenge the pain that we
face every time I talk to you you give
me a new perspective on how to view my
life and how to understand how how we
get through things yeah yeah well I
guess say the feeling's mutual man and
you know your your book on and your
teaching on finding your why has been so
instrumental in my life because I've
never been able to articulate it that
way but when I talk about that vision
that's on the other side of the cross
that's your why you know and and that's
what has kept me gone for instance the
whole story behind my career is that I
never wanted to play football and it was
in during my senior year when my best
friend my childhood best friend was
killed and he was the quarterback of the
team which basically inspired me to play
football and even when I got drafted
when they called me and Bill Parcells
said would you like to be a New England
Patriot and I told him yes and as soon
as I hung up the phone I told everyone
else who was at my house that I really
didn't want to play and it was this guy
there
his name was pastor Leroy Joseph and he
said to me said well Curtis maybe
football's just the vehicle that God has
given you to do all those wonderful
things you said you want to do in our
community and around the world and it
was that that helped me to lock into
football and work as hard as I possibly
could to make the most of it because in
my mind every yard I gained every
touchdown I scored it just opened up
more doors for me to reach more people
and so all the pain that you endure and
I endured door
NFL career it was always with that why
in the back of my mind that okay I'm
going to be able to change and help
other people's lives by making it
through this pain and being successful
Curtis it was tragedy that inspired you
to become a football player it was what
you could do the glory that you saw by
working hard and enduring pain for
others and I think we're in the same
place as a society as a nation it's
tragedy that has called us to do
something unbelievably difficult yeah
that's gonna require a lot of hard work
and there will be pain but it's about
it's about getting back to huddle it's
about keeping going it's about enduring
and taking steps and taking the steps
and working together exactly we all have
a part to play you know just one last
story assignment one of my greatest
accomplishments in my life beyond Hall
of Fame and Super Bowl and all that any
contracts whatever any material thing
none of that nothing compared to me
helping and somewhat nurturing my own
mother to get to the place where she
could forgive my father you know he left
when I was five years old and I remember
when I was 27 22 years later my mother
and I were riding through our old
neighborhood and we saw my father
standing at the bus stop and I said mom
look big on my dad and she says what
would you tell me for so what I said
well I bet you he's going home I mean
why don't we give him a ride and Simon I
mean she really lit into me cursed me
out I'm not giving that mother effer a
ride no we're effort and we're not if
you think you get off time telling me to
get after all he did to us and you know
she goes into all that for you know 30
seconds or so and I said to I said mom
listen I just got to say something you
know I never talked back to you I've
always respected you I said but you are
the angriest bitterest person I know and
you've been like that since I was a kid
I was like you've never really shown me
well I just know that that you love me
but you've never showed me love
hi kissing me on my forehead or telling
me that just wasn't a part of our
conversation in our household
and I believe it's because you're so
bitter and I believe you're so bitter
because of that man standing right there
at the bus stop that you need to give a
ride and you need to forgive so that you
can release yourself because well I
don't think that I've really met the
mother that I was supposed to have all
my life and I'm still not experiencing
that mother simply because of that man
who left 22 years ago and Simon my
mother the light turns green and she
drives through the light and pulls over
on the other side of the street but she
says you know Kurt Astra father she
needs a ride and I remember before she
even did that Simon I think this is what
really made it click for her I said mom
just think about this you're mad at him
because he left us when I was 5 years
old I'm 27 years old you're still as mad
as the day that he left I said I'll
think about it this way do you think
that we would experience the life that
we experienced now do you think that I
would be the man that I am today if he
was there as my example all those years
the Simon I really believe it that's
what it just clicked to her I heard the
same one time that said these
psychologist and psychiatrist they were
trying to figure out why people become
bitter in life and what they discovered
after all their study was that people
don't become bitter because of what they
experienced in life but they become
bitter because of how they remember what
they experienced in life and so I
realized that my mother the only memory
she had and that was how my father left
us in the condition that he left us in
she never even thought about Wow what if
he was there he would have been my son's
example all these years and my son
probably would have turned out the way
he did so she gives him a ride they have
a conversation
I let him sit in the front seat I get in
the back seat we get to his house and he
walks up the steps and shuts his door
and goes in and my mother turns around
to me and just starts bawling her eyes
out and I never seen my mother really
cry that hard and she said I Kurt I feel
like I just dropped off Oh
bricks thank you so much for pushing me
to give your father a rat and Simon from
that moment on my father and my mother
began to develop a relationships where
when he was on his deathbed and came
down with stage four cancer she was
cooking him food she was taking them to
his doctor's appointments she was
picking up his medicine and they had a
beautiful relationship before he passed
and coming out of his funeral she held
my hand and just told me she said Kurt I
don't know what I would have done if
your father had died and never knew that
I forgave him and she thanked me hmm
Curtis thank you so much I I say again
you are like a monk to me you know but
you're a spiritual advisor to me and
your perspective your stories I'm just
I'm just grateful I appreciate your time
I appreciate everything you do
glad glad you're in my life really am
well likewise man and thanks for having
me today I enjoyed appreciate it thank
you
I encourage everyone who listened to
please call your friends and have some
of those uncomfortable conversations and
have some comforting ones too we all
need to figure out how we can help each
other work through fear and pain now
more than ever take care of yourself
take care of each other